Fant for stick is directed by josh trank
at stars miles teller Michael B Jordan
kate mara and Jamie Bell and is the 4th
live-action Fantastic Four movie
yes I'm counting that straight to VHS
thing that happened in the 90s as well
as the two other films that you probably
saw and hated just like me
this film once again is trying to tell
the story of Reed Richards Sue Storm
Johnny Storm and Ben Grimm for people
who come together on a science project
and are given magical powers one of them
can stretch another person can turn
invisible ones like a rock monster and
the other one can fly and turn into fire
the first one from the 90s was laughably
bad and historically awful in every way
and the second two films are also
hysterically awful yet they're still
trying again to breathe some life into
the Fantastic Four they brought on the
director of Chronicle a film I clearly
liked I thought this was a pretty good
found footage film one of the better
ones we've gotten in recent years also
starring Michael B Jordan and you guys
have all heard the bad buzz the biggest
of which was that Josh Trank was in line
to direct one of the Star Wars anthology
films and now he's mysteriously not
anymore now we've all had the privilege
to see comic book movies really come
into their own in the past ten years or
so they've evolved they've changed it's
been proven time and time again now that
you can take various comic book
characters no matter how big or how
small they are in regards to popularity
and make a fun and entertaining movie
out of them Marvel is doing a great job
with that and I honestly thought we were
in a time we would no longer see a truly
atrocious comic book film well we were
beyond the Batman and Robin we've moved
past the Superman for quest for peace we
will no longer receive movies like Ghost
Rider well guys I was wrong fan for
stick is one of the worst superhero
films I've ever seen here we go this
entire film is nothing but exposition it
is leading to a film that never happens
the villain Victor Von Doom is laughably
atrociously awful the way he looks is a
comedy the way he acts is a comedy the
movie is so convinced that it has to set
up a world a world in which we can have
sequels we have to copy off of the
Avengers success the Marvel routine in
which they set up an entire world in
which these characters exist a world
that we can enjoy and we can make
of money because it's a big franchise in
a big world now fans for stick is so
intent on creating this world in which
all these various puzzle pieces are put
together to create a franchise in which
we can continue to make more of these
that it forgets to make an entertaining
movie on its own at some point we have
now pushed beyond the idea of making a
great movie and because it's so great
people want more now we have to make a
movie that sets up another movie that
sets up another movie we can't make good
movies anymore we just make movies that
set up other movies like the amazing
spider-man 2 so we sat down and we're
like well guys we didn't really make the
greatest movie with Amazing Spiderman we
can do better
let's make amazing spider-man 2 and make
it just as good as Sam Raimi's
spider-man 2 or we could just make a
movie in which every scene is setting up
a sinister six movie or amazing
spider-man 3 and not give a about
making a good movie and that's exactly
what Fant for stick is doing and I'm
going to keep calling it that because
that's what they put on the poster kind
of like scruff forum there are certain
things in a movie like this that you
expect to be good that you almost just
assume will be good for instance the CGI
with a movie that has this much money
behind it you expect at least the CGI in
the production value and the costume
design to be good there's a shot of this
movie in which Reed Richards after he
becomes a stretchy guy warps his face to
look like someone else to be in disguise
when he warps back into Reed Richards
it looked like a movie that came out in
1993 that was trying to use CGI effects
that weren't invented yet I'm not
exaggerating there wasn't a single thing
convincing about it the CGI in this
movie is so incredibly transparent to
the point where every single shot in
which CGI exists
feels as if you are peering into some
strange animated cartoon world that is
not real even some of the green screen
in this movie is so horrific Lee
noticeable that there isn't a single
shot in this film where you can actually
feel as if you are watching a world that
exists somewhere towards the end of this
movie they are asking you to care about
earth people are in peril because of
something terrible it's happening with
Doctor Doom you're supposed to care it's
supposed to be the moment of truth when
which everyone comes together and you're
like yeah Fantastic Four all right but
you don't care because the movie never
takes the time to set up this world you
don't give a about anything that's
happening as far as I'm concerned Doctor
Doom succeeding in what he's trying to
do what
been a more interesting movie than the
one that we actually got even certain
script points didn't make sense I don't
want to get into spoilers but in all
honesty there's barely anything to spoil
because this entire movie is so
incredibly uneventful that nothing
really happens if you've seen a trailer
you know the major beats this movie the
Fantastic Four get their powers Victor
Von dooms a bad guy they have a little
battle there's nothing to spoil nothing
happens
this movie is honestly just as bad as
batman and robin or superman for a quest
for peace but the difference is a film
like Batman and Robin is so campy it
does not take itself seriously you can
actually watch that movie and make fun
of it and laugh at how bad it is
fantastic is taking itself seriously it
is trying to be the Dark Knight of the
Fantastic Four and it sucks so
incredibly hard that you just sit there
bored out of your mind waiting for
anything to happen so the entire film is
exposition the relationships in the
movie come off as forced and awkward the
comedic jokes don't even work I barely
laughed at all I wanted to like this
movie I loved almost every member of
this cast Milo's teller is very talented
Michael B Jordan is awesome kate mara
and Jamie Bell are all very good actors
Tim Blake Nelson is in this movie what
the hell happened everything in this
movie dropped the ball everything I
don't want to watch I'd rather watch
Batman and Robin again I'm being
completely serious
everything about fan for stick sucks
there isn't a single redeeming quality
in this entire film even the
performances that kind of work because
you can see these are talented people
they don't work because the things
they're saying have virtually no
interest there isn't a single surprise
in this entire film and when even the
CGI in costume design and especially the
look of Doctor Doom who looks like a
total complete moron everything fails
this movie fails guys fan for stick gets
an F
I am in utter shock at how bad this
movie was this is the first real total
disaster of 2015 and I'm not
exaggerating I swear to you I'm not
every single thing about this movie
failed I can see someone watching this
movie and saying it wasn't that bad
Chris you're being too hard on it if you
like movies guys obviously I don't
recommend this film go see ant-man again
go see Mission Impossible rogue nation
anything really uh guys thank you so
much as always for watching if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]
[Applause]